Yeah, we'd have a we'd have a whole
conversation. We're 30 minutes in. We're
like, "Hey, should we record this this
conversation?"
>> Um, I think I have the AI uh summary uh
recording. All right. So, so um this is
the uh interview with uh Alan Drau and
Brian Curts. Um I so um so the one of
the things that's one of my premises
also is that I I see myself as like a
bridge between you know cuz a lot of
people who you know grew up even in the
in the um in the uh
direct marketing of the 80s and 90s. um
a lot of them aren't around or they're
not they're not here to tell the tale
and also I made the transition from
offline to online because I was a
student of online in fact you know
that's why I don't turn down podcasts I
don't turn down interviews with
especially with you know younger more
dynamic marketers than myself because I
really want to learn from them and so I
mean you know I'm in masterminds with,
you know, usually I'm one of the oldest
people in every mastermind I'm a member
of and I get in on a golden ticket
because, you know, they think I know
something and so it's an advantage. So,
I get like, oh yeah, you can you can
join, Brian. That's fine. Even though
you don't know what the [__] you're
talking about when it comes to online
[__] But I also I can be dangerous in
some online areas. But of course, I know
I know my limitations. I know what I
don't know. Well, I don't I don't know
what I don't know, but I also know what
I don't know. And so I I'm a teacher,
but I'm also a student. And you know,
and this goes back to breakthrough
advertising. I was a student of Jean
Schwarz, and I you know, and many other,
you know, greats of marketing. I want to
continue that trend. But you can't you
can't just you can't be a teacher
without always learning. So that's
always been a premise for me. So, I'm
like I'm a bridge that connects all of
that with everything that's
state-of-the-art today. Not that I'm
doing state-of-the-art, but I know
state-of-the-art. And I bring in
state-of-the-art people into my
mastermind to speak. And I know I know
what I don't know. You know, I know I
know what I know and I know what I don't
know. And so, why not, you know, you
can't be an expert in everything. So,
why not, you know, bring in the experts?
So that's kind of like the whole T-Rex
and and you know that that's where it
originates basically.
>> I think that's great and in fact I think
it's a perfect actually segue to why
we're having a conversation today
because the thing that actually drew me
to reach out to Chris Mason who's our
mutual connection. Right.
>> Right. I reached out to Chris because in
my era of copy, I'm 32, so I'm not the
youngest, but I'm not I'm not the the
oldest in the game, right? I've I've got
a lot to learn in in this. But in my era
of copywriting, what's happening is and
you know what's happening is that
everybody right now is in the AI golden
age, right? The AI golden age. And I'm
looking around and I'm seeing all my
fellow friends, uh, competitors,
whatever you want to call them, co
coexistence of competition as you like
to teach, right? In that sense, I'm
seeing everybody selling AI prompts and
all these things. And I was really drawn
back over the last 6 months to be like,
man, I need to go through this book
again. I need to I need to dive into
this because right now every I feel like
fundamentals is a lost art.
>> Yeah. No. And it's it it becomes a
differentiator of sorts, you know, like
direct mail is a differentiator because
no one, you know, it's like what's this?
You go to you go to some younger
marketers, they go direct mail, is that
is that a new medium? You know, it's
like
>> um and so that's fine. That's fine. Um
but and again, it's direct mail is
different today than it was then. I
mean, you can't do the kinds of mailings
I did at Boardroom anymore. It's just
they don't really exist. you know, doing
a 9 million piece mailing for a oneshot
book at $39 doesn't happen. You can't
find 9 million direct you can't you
can't find that many names to mail that
you could even make get close to
profitable. On the other hand, direct
mail on the back end of any any any
online business is a differentiator. And
the the irony is I So I'm in I'm in Jeff
Walker's mastermind. You know Jeff
Walker?
>> Oh, cool. Yeah, I do know Jeff Walker
through Chris Orzikowski.
>> Say again.
>> I know Jeff Walker through Chris
Orzowski, who's my man.
>> Chris Orzikowski, right?
>> And um yeah, Chris is promoting uh PLF,
I saw.
>> Yeah, he did.
>> Yeah. So, um I I was I was invited to
Jeff Walker's mastermind as a guest
speaker.
>> Okay.
>> Which blew me away. I mean, it was like
a it was a great story. I think I told
it in a blog. I might have. I think I
told it in my book too in chapter 10
where Jeff Walker sent out a LinkedIn
request and said, you know, um, you
know, is is this the Brian Curts? And I
sent him an email back. I said, "Is this
the Jeff Walker?" And we knew of each
other before. We might have even met,
but we weren't really connected that
well. And we got into an email dialogue.
I think we probably got on a phone call.
Um, Zoom wasn't popular yet then. It was
like 11 years ago. Um, and he said, "Why
don't you come to my mastermind? You'll
come, you'll do a presentation, you'll
hang out with my my my wonderful online
PLF marketers." And I never left because
I I went there as a speaker. Um, I I it
was like a love grip, you know, I love
them, they love me, and they I just
joined. I always said it was a ploy by
Jeff to get $25,000 a year from me for
12 years. Um, so that's an ongoing joke,
but it's amazing. I mean, being exposed
to that group was one of the gifts of my
career.
>> I mean, I'm talking about, you know,
you're talking about, you know, Stu
McLaren and and um I can't even begin to
name all of the amazing marketers who've
been part of, you know, Jeff Walker's
Ryan Le, I mean, so many. Uh, Will
Hamilton, amazing, amazing marketers.
And I got in on a on a technicality. I
mean, if I if I had applied if Jeff
didn't know me and I had applied for his
mastermind when I joined, which was
probably 2012
may uh what's what's this year? 2025.
>> 2025.
>> Yeah, probably 2013 maybe. Anyway, if I
had applied, I would have been rejected,
you know. But
>> why why do you think that? cuz I'm not I
he was mostly he mo I it's my own maybe
it's my own perception I would have been
rejected because I wasn't doing launches
traditional launch.
>> Okay. Now, interestingly, when I got
there that first year, um, and this we
could relate back to Jean Schwarz and
everything, but I I do think that when I
by the time I got there, um, he he had
just started bringing in other like not
generalists, but people in other areas
of marketing of of um of, you know, uh,
uh, public people who are who are doing
different things than just launching
online products.
>> Two of them, one was Victoria Lab.
Victoria Lab is like an amazing public
speaker. She teaches speaking. She works
with corporate executives. And Annie
Annie Heyman Pratt who is like an
organizational expert and she changed
all the companies in Jeff's group
because she taught them how to build a
business and not a product or a
promotion. you know, actually build a
business with like a with like a
structure and employees and like a way
to like, you know, make a profit and
because most of the people in Jeff's
group at the beginning, they were launch
they live launch to launch. It was like
and and one launch doesn't do well of
the two or three you do a year, your
your business is bad for the whole year.
>> So, yeah.
>> So, and so I saw them there the first
time I went there as a speaker and I
said, "Oh, this isn't just all
launchers." So maybe, but if I had if I
had applied when he offered it
originally,
um I was unqualified to be in it based
on his criteria. Definitely.
>> That's interesting because I think one
of the things you mentioned in overd
deliver is that you're in like six to
eight masterminds
>> over time. Not all at the same time, but
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. And I I I over time I've been in
different ones. Some of them I don't pay
for. Some of them I pay a lot for. Um,
some of them are not masterminds, but
they're coaching groups, whatever. But
yeah, I mean, I I' I've I tried to
calculate it. I've spent well over a
million dollars in my career on
mastermind, including all the travel and
everything that goes with it.
>> Well over a million dollars in my educa.
That's my education, though. I I
consider that my tuition to be a
legitimate direct response marketer.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Oh,
>> in addition in addition to like you know
all the basics that I knew originally
starting with Jean Schwarz.
>> Yeah, that's going to be a bullet to
promote this. How much has Brian Kurts
paid in tuition to learn his direct
response life? I love it. We're going to
we're going to use that. But a lot of
that
>> also and that the boot camp is only 297
tells you you know so you can actually
do a you could do like a thing there.
You can do 297 to a million or you can
do 297
to um one mastermind at $25,000 and look
at the and you'll get more in two weeks.
I'm giving you the copy, but you you're
the copywriter, but
>> I'm going to price anchor them at a
million.
>> Yeah, anchor them at a million, right?
Um
>> that's awesome.
>> But you you know if you can do you can
do it in two weeks, six 90 minute calls.
It's like a mini mastermind of epic
proportions, right?
>> I did. I told that was the first thing I
told because I got on a call with Chris
a couple weeks ago and I was taking
notes. I was like, "Hey, send me the
landing page." Uh, and he sent me the
landing page. I was like, "Hey, the uh
price is wrong. You're missing a one in
front of the or you're missing a couple
ones in front of the in front of the
boot camp." And he's like, "No, it's
that's the price." And I was like, "At
the book is 120. Are you sure?"
>> Yeah. and and he's like
>> first time we did the boot camp it was
99.
>> I it's I think that's insane.
>> But the thing is I my business was
launched on a descension model meaning
that when I left boardroom the first
product that I launched
>> was a $20,000 mastermind.
>> So because I look I had 34 years of of
connections and relationship capital. So
I could bring I brought I I immediately
sold 23 companies into my mastermind
within weeks. So
>> yeah,
>> do the math. That's $400,000. That's a
business
>> at a 40% margin, right?
>> So I did that and then I I but I I I I
um I I I froze it at 30 companies
>> which had some people had partners also.
So I froze my mastermind. But I but I
had up to 45 members at 20 or 25,000.
That's a business in itself. Pl not not
including Jean Schwarz and Breakthrough
Advertising, not including other things
I was doing. So it was um and then so
everything was that was everything
descended from there as opposed to I
didn't start with the $99 product to get
to the $25,000 mastermind. So now on the
low ticket, I didn't care that much
about the low ticket because the low
ticket like gravy and I wanted to reach
more people. So there was a method to
the madness. I definitely underpriced it
intentionally. My mastermind, my Titans
Accelerator mastermind, which is 2,000 a
year, is totally underpriced, but I want
to bring in as many, you know, people as
possible so that I can reach more people
and, you know, spread spread spread the
gospel of what I know and get the gospel
from them. And so, a lot of younger
marketers 2,000 is a lot of money, I
found.
>> Yeah.
>> So,
>> yeah, you're not you're not wrong. And
actually that that is why we're having
the conversation today is because I feel
the same thing except you know you've
gotten to actually spend time with these
people like Jean you've actually gotten
to spend time with legends Benga Deutsch
all these guys and I'm building uh an
email list of copywriters and I'm
running into all these people who are
like who who are these and I'm like are
you serious? Have you not have you not
dove into this? Who are you reading? Who
are you listening to? and and it is an
advantage that you know I touched all of
them. So literally I've touched them.
I've hugged I've hugged most of them.
But that it's funny someone once came up
to me at a at a conference who was a
Jean Schwarz fan young didn't you know
learned about Jean Schwarz you know
after he was dead. um which which
fascinates me too. Like the fact that
you're you know you're now a Jean
Schwarz groupy just by being on the
phone with me um is very satisfying for
me. You know you know you you know
you're you're a new fan but you'll be a
lifelong fan and
>> sure
>> but I was at a conference and some
32year-old came up to me and said you
know um um I heard I heard you've
touched Jean Schwarz. I said, "Yeah, I
said I even hugged him a few times,
>> Brian. You're feeding me the bullets.
You're just g
this. That's amazing."
>> So, I mean, in that, not only have you
gotten a hug, Jean Schwarz, I have heard
that you actually used to go to his
penthouse.
>> Yes.
>> And and and talk commerce, talk sales
letters when you were back at boardroom.
>> Is tell me about that.
>> Yeah. So basically um Jean Schwarz and
Marty Edelston the founder of Boardroom.
They were buddies. They knew each other
from Marty's work in he used to Marty
used to sell um space advertising direct
response space advertising in magazines
and things like that. So he got to know
all of the copywriters. Mart Marty was
an amazing connector himself. And so he
met Jean and they were friends. I think
Jean Gan wrote an ad for the a Jewish
encyclopedia that Marty found and he was
obsessed with it. He thought it was the
most amazing copy and he sought Gan out.
I don't know exactly how they met but it
was close to that. And so um so Jean was
writing copy for us and we could we'll
talk I know one of your questions is
about you know writing copy for names.
Um, yeah, but but
>> he was writing copy for us and look, I
was in the marketing department. I I got
to meet Jean when he came to the office
and all of that.
>> And, you know, he liked me. I liked him.
It wasn't an intimate relationship
initially. I was like a little pitcher,
you know. I was like I was like the kid,
you know, the marketing kid. Not even
the marketing director. I was the
marketing kid. And
>> were you still a list manager at this
point? You were just listening. when I
met him I was or I was no I wasn't I had
already started doing I I actually
probably was the marketing director by
then where I was but I used all my list
management knowledge to be a marketing
director because I basically
was was looking at our mailings and I I
dealt with our the lists we had to mail
like I did when I sold the boardroom
lists because it it's the same thing.
It's sort of like um you know what are
the what what are the what's what are
the promotions that got the name. It was
always how I always looked at lists
because we had the best copywriters, you
know, and so, you know, I knew that our
lists were great because of the
copywriters that were creating them,
whether it was Jean or Mel Martin or Ben
Svena came around a little later than
that, but he was there. And so it was
like the the copy was so impulsive. All
fascinations, bullets, all of that. And
the kind of person that would respond to
that kind of a package knowing that
we're going after executives, people who
are affluent already, and now they're
mail order junkies, too. Like all they
want to do is buy more through direct
mail.
>> You could see why the boardroom lists
were like, you know, a crown jewel of
the list industry. So then when I went
into the marketing side, I looked at
every list that I mailed. whatever list
I always I my list brokers had to give
me. I had this I wrote a blog post about
this. It was guilty until proven
innocent. And I developed this worksheet
where my list brokers I mean I was a
pain in the ass client to my list
brokers. I said you got to fill out this
worksheet for every list you're
recommending. And one of the things on
the worksheet was that you also had to
attach a sample of the mailing piece
that got the names on that list.
And that would tell me more than
anything else if if I they could connect
if I could connect the promotion. I
could for instance, you know, Agora,
they were using all the same
copywriters. Phyllis Publishing was
using all the same copywriters. If I saw
a Phyllis Publishing list that was using
uh a Gary Benga written package or a Jim
Ruts written package, I knew that list
was going to kick ass for Boardroom.
>> You know, I mean, Agora at the time was
a lot smaller. It wasn't a
billion-dollar business back then, but
and I knew I knew them from the start. I
mean, Bill Bonner was one of my one of
my early mentors, too. And I knew Mark
Ford very
>> Oh, yeah. I mean, Agora Agora and
Boardroom were always very very close.
And we were so close that we exchanged
so many names with each other that um we
I always when we did a merge purge of in
our mailings if I had an agora list in
there merging against the list in the
mailing and my house list I get a 40%
duplication. I mean, we were Whoa.
>> Yeah, it was it was but the not but
again, you're going out with different
promotion and I have a whole story about
that when Bill Bonner imitated one of
our packages and he couldn't get the
same result even though the lists are
the same. You think they're not. There's
the gestalt of the mailing which is has
to do with the list the the every
there's so many factors. It's not it's
not based on one factor but there was a
lot of overlap on the lists. So anyway,
the the idea was so I what connected me
to Jean was was an amazing thing because
I I was just talking to him one day in
the office as I recall and he had his
little book company, Instant
Improvement, the tower sexology and how
to rub your stomach away and all all
that [__] I mean
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. content wasn't great. The
promotions were amazing. I mean swipe
file. And so we're I'm talking to him
and I said, you know, what kind of list
do you mail besides boardroom in Rodale
and he said, you know, my list broker
does I knew his list broker list, don't
put this in the uh in the although I'm
sure the guy's dead, but the guy was an
[__] Um and his company were
[__] but it was just that was who
his list broker was. And so I said,
"Jean, let me look at the list plans
they do for you and I'll take a look and
make sure you're getting because you got
to be mailing all the health lists we're
mailing because we had health products
as well."
>> And so he gave me the list. I remember
he gave me a list plan.
>> Some of they didn't have anywhere near
the all the lists that they should have.
>> And the list that they were mailing
didn't have the right selections. Like
there was specific like on a Rodale list
even on Rodale you needed to take
certain segments based on their their
promotion patterns if they're if they're
if they're mailing a a women's book you
know in in the last six months primarily
you don't want those names you want the
names of the people who bought the men's
book the six months before even without
recency so it was like those kinds of
subtleties in the selections and so I
just basically redid Jean's list plan I
of course I wasn't going charge him or
anything. And it it it it basically I I
I did it without any expectation. Just I
wanted to do it. It's [__] Jean
Schwarz, you know.
>> And and so I remember him saying that
and then he did mailings. They did much
better, of course. Um I mean, I didn't
do the mailing, but I got him the best
list selections.
>> And so then he
>> he we we he just like it's I always say,
you don't choose your mentors, your
mentors choose you. and he chose me as a
mentee basically because you know I I
just I just overd delivered to him in a
way because I first of all I love the
guy he's he's you know great guy warm um
gentle um had a temper you know if Marty
disagreed with one of his headlines he
would get he would get pissed off um
>> he's protective about his work
>> yeah he was very protective of his work
um But he um he befriended me. So then
you know I would go to his house you
know a couple of time maybe I don't know
maybe not every month but you know I go
there we'd have lunch in his big dining
room. The he he was a he was a major
modern art collector and he had tons of
stuff in storage and in the penthouse
all over. And so every time I went
there, it was a different collection
because he would move the paintings out
after 6 months and bring in another
whole set of paintings. And he
discovered him and his wife Barbara,
they who's still alive, who gets
royalties on Breakthrough Advertising.
>> They they both um they were incredible
art collectors and they discovered so
many young artists who are famous today,
modern artists. And in fact in I I wrote
this somewhere but in Jean's obituary
um there were in New York Times it was a
lengthy obituary and it was all about
his art collecting prowess. There's one
paragraph about Oh and he had a book
publishing company and wrote some copy.
>> Are you serious? That's awesome.
>> Yeah. So I did I did spend a and I spent
a lot of quality time with him, you
know, learning. I mean, he he was he was
really instructive. He one of the one of
the great lines is um that I've used a
lot is he said to me um I remember
handing him a big health an encyclopedic
health book that we had and I said you
know gene you know you're going to write
a package for this and his first
question his first question was always
what's not in the book what's not in the
newsletter
>> and what he was trying to do there was
to spur some addition traditional
uh curiosity both in me and our editors.
>> So um and I'll fast forward to because
like the copywriters of today, the best
ones do the same thing. Parisopropolis,
I've told this story in a blog.
Parisopropolis was doing a package for
my natural healing newsletter and I
said, "Can you do a package for this?"
He read the past issues. He looked at
the control package, whoever wrote it,
he said, "I don't want to write for
this. There's nothing exciting in here."
And I said, "No, nothing cutting edge.
It's all the same shit." And I said, "He
doesn't want to, you know, Paris can
only be as good as the as the content."
Now, sometimes you can make your
fascinations better than the content.
>> Whatever whatever whatever on an
airplane is much better than the answer,
>> you know, that's okay because you got to
titilate people. So he and we came up
with this idea. Paris said, "Let me talk
to the editor of of the natural healing
newsletter and he met with him and
basically his one question was, "What
are you not putting in the newsletter?"
Same as Gene would say, "What's not in
the book?"
>> And the editor had like tons of articles
that were the the guru. We had a guru on
that newsletter, a doctor, a naturopath
doctor, and he had many articles that he
put in on cutting edge therapies and
cutting edge stuff that our editors
rejected
because they were very conservative, our
editors. So then we got to the crux of
the problem. Now, was some of the stuff
still controversial? Yeah. I mean, urine
therapy is controversial. Even at that
time, Chilation was very controversial.
But what Paris
um encourage them to do is go find on
some of these studies find more proof so
I can use it in the package and he
pushed them couldn't get stuck we're not
going to lie we're not going to we're
not going to say untruths in in the copy
but go find me stuff that can support
this material and they got a lot of new
stuff and it always became the lead in
his package or in his sales letter
because it was always the most cutting
edge stuff and the most exciting to
write about. And I think that's a I
don't know if Gene invented that, but
Jean I got it from Jean. And I think
Paris
Paris has such a an amazing um I don't
know. He's just got he's got that six
sense and he's got he's got a he's got a
copy he's got the gene, you know. If
there is a gene for copywriting, Paris
got it. And a lot of it's his curiosity
and his inquisitiveness and his
>> never never never settle for the first
answer. All of that because the best
copywriters are the best interviewers,
you know, always.
>> And
>> yeah. So anyway, I mean, I I I learned a
lot from Jean um at those meetings, but
also every time I saw him work, every
time I saw him write a package, he was
he was um I mean, and a little side side
note that just shows his his dedication
to the craft and how he never let it go.
Um uh you might know this, but he had a
major stroke where he
>> Yeah. Yeah. All if you've seen the
Rodell um uh thing, you'd see that his
his his right arm is by his side the
whole time. He's only motioning with one
hand.
>> And
>> this is why he wrote a specific sales
letter, right? One sales letter he did
for free because the guy
um actually helped him solve after his
stroke. He tell he said he helped me get
movement back in my right arm, which is
>> I haven't heard that story
interestingly.
>> Yeah, he didn't get much movement back.
He could lift it up. When he shook your
hand, it was like shaking a sponge.
>> Um.
>> Oh,
>> yeah. You know, he didn't have a lot of
feeling in his right arm. He basically
the point is that he ended up doing
hunting and pecking on a manual type.
That's why the manual typewriter is on
the cover of Breakthrough Advertising.
>> Oh.
>> Cuz he hunted and pecked. He hunted and
picked on on that keyboard on a query
keyboard
>> basically with one finger and he wrote
volumes of copy that way.
>> Oh my goodness. Now that obviously now
he does speak into that for sure when he
I think it's uh his his Phillips speech
when he when he talked at Phillips he's
got those like three sessions that are
broken out because he breaks them out in
333. He does it three times.
>> Right. Right. The Pomodoro method.
>> Yeah. Is that called the Pomodoro
method? the 33 timer.
That might be it. It It might be that.
But in that, so we do get that quirk
from Jean. He obviously pumped out a ton
of copy. You got to spend a lot of time
with him. Was he always in this like
really like deep work mode or or did he
have he had a lot of the the art
collection?
>> Yeah. No, he was very he was a very
eclectic guy. when when he was talking
business, he was talking business, but
no, he was he was an eclectic guy. He
liked baseball. We didn't get into too
much baseball, but um no, he was um
>> he was he was focused all the time, but
he was one of the one of the reasons
that made him a great copywriter.
There's a quote in one of the my blogs,
you know, it's about it's about, you
know, about art and what's out in the
world. It's also like the other quote
is, you know, if you don't if you don't
spend, you know, time with your market,
you're finished. Basically, if you don't
spend time being out in the world in
your I mean, John Carlton talks about
that when he talks about,
>> you know, being being mindful of
everything around you and not, you know,
some people think to write copy, you put
headphones on,
cut out all the noise, sit in a dark
room and write or sit in a light room
and write. And he did it differently. He
always I mean his favorite magazine was
a national inquirer because he really ex
he really wanted to see what what makes
this country tick
>> you know what makes people vibrate.
Marty used to ter use the term I want my
I want your copy to vibrate. Um and he
knew what had what made people vibrate
in terms of what what what are people
talking about? what are they in not to
write current events into a mailing
package. He didn't do a lot of that
because it was dangerous in direct mail
because you write a package, it's not
going to go out for six or nine months
or or at least 6 months or maybe even
four months. But current events change
very quickly. They're not current
anymore. But he just wanted to get a
sense of what people were thinking about
and he says know what your market is
thinking about all the time. And that
was part of his writing ability. Um
it was um it's the Pomodoro technique by
the way. Um
it it's and and it it's basic, you know,
and he did it with 33 minutes, 33
seconds, but you can do it with 10
minutes, whatever, but you have to it's
basically, you know, intense
release, intense release. And the
release you walk, but he would walk
around outside. He'd take a walk
outside. He, you know, he wanted, he was
an observer of culture. He was an
observer of people. Um, he was, um, you
know, Dan Kennedy says, you know, he
always talks about, you know, marketing
by walking around.
>> Um,
>> you know, Gene was copyrighting by
walking around.
>> Um, yeah. you know, and it's the same
thing basically because copywriting and
marketing are linked, but it it's it's
it's um
it's an important aspect of being a
great copywriter.
>> Yeah. No, it is. And that's one of the
reasons why I think it's very
interesting today that that we're having
a conversation about a guy who has been
passed for over 20 years, 25 years in
that sense. a book that was written 60
years ago,
>> 1966, 100% relevant. There's not one
thing in that book that's not relevant.
T
>> talk about that for a sec. Why is this
book so timeless? Why is it so prolific?
And why should people in 2025,
especially I got a bunch of new
copywriters on my list, people watching
YouTube, people diving into this and
they're and they're into the AI world
and they're into these cool new offers
in internet marketing. And when you talk
about a book that's been around for 60
years, they're like,"Wh would I need to
know that?"
>> Well, you know, they should read
Scientific Advertising, which was
written in 1923. So, it's not just 1966.
And the reason is I wrote it in my in my
afterward to to the Titans marketing
edition is that human behavior hasn't
changed since 1966.
Nor has it changed since I think in in
the after I say nor has it changed since
1066.
>> So humans are humans still. And so the
book is not there's a lot of copy in it.
There's a lot about copy and marketing
and markets and being a market maker and
you know um mass desire and you know but
the whole specifically the levels of
aware the the states of awareness and
levels of sophistication
>> is something that is not just about
marketing. It's about human behavior.
And so they're they're just and and the
thing is the way he goes into it, he
goes into it in a very dense way, very
specific in the book.
>> Yes.
>> That's why the boot camp is so valuable
because you know, you've seen all the
copy that we've written previously on
the boot camp. It's it's that it's dense
and because it's dense, you may not want
to pick it up and read it. And if you
pick it up and read it, you still might
not get turn it into a utility. And
there's no reason you're going to spend
$125 for a book that you're gonna skim
and not adapt to your business. And
that's where the boot camp comes in
because the boot camp gives you the
opportunity.
You're forced to read it basically. It's
sort of like when I when I wrote my book
overd deliver, I one of the great things
was doing the audio version. You know,
for two days I had to read my book.
>> I got new insights into the book that I
just wrote
>> by doing the audio version.
>> You're like, "Brian, this is good. This
is really good, Brian."
>> Yeah. But then Yeah. Then I said, "This
is bad. I [__] that up." And we I
tried to make some changes, which I
couldn't. Um Well, we actually were able
to make some changes at that point. Um
not big changes. I could change words
and stuff, but but then you read
Breakthrough Advertising and you'd say,
"God, this is deep. I I how do I adapt
it? How do I approach using it?" And
that's what that was the challenge that
Chris and I were faced with um to create
the boot camp like how can we make this
a utility like make it that's what I'm
trying to do with my mastermind. I'm
trying to do I'm using AI to create
intense summaries with actionable things
from every guest speaker.
>> It's it's it may I may not be able to
pull it off, but I'm trying. I'm working
with Max Bernstein who's a a good
copywriter who's
>> skilled in AI. I'm not skilled in AI. I
know what AI can do and what it can't
do. But I um and he's in fact I was just
thinking about it today because I just
edited like the first summary using AI
and you know it's it's not good enough
because we want to make it a paid
subscription on Substack as an entry
into Titans Accelerator. So
>> sort of like Breakthrough Advertising
Boot Camp is is an entry into Titans
Accelerator. this Substack subscription.
It's sort of like Titans Accelerator
Light because it's summaries of the
calls, but they have to be actionable.
And so the Breakthrough Advertising Boot
Camp was a way to make Breakthrough
Advertising actionable. And then, of
course, that's that spawn Breakthrough
Advertising Mastery, which is also
um worth buying, but they don't have to
buy it to be in the boot camp. But
bridge advertising mastery was basically
and it it was a it was a happy accident.
A young c why I pay attention to young
copywriters and you're included now. Um
you know this guy um uh Luis Flavio
Luis
Luis Flav has three names. Luis Flavio I
top my head. So he sends me an email and
he said again young copywriter from
Brazil. um
knows Jean Schwarz. He's probably he's
probably like 28 years old. Sends me an
email. I mean, these are the these are
the best emails I ever get, you know?
It's like a 28-year-old studying Jean
Schwarz. This guy I I love this guy, you
know.
>> Oh, already in your good graces.
>> You are too. You are too.
>> I appreciate it. I appreciate it.
>> I didn't know you and you know, but
Chris said I've got I've got a guy
that's right up your alley. He's he's 30
whatever and he's 30some and he's a Jean
Schwarz groupy. I said I'll talk to him,
you know.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I love that.
>> So Luis Luis Flavio Nunees and he sends
he sends me a proposal to do this is a
55th anniversary of Breakthrough
Advertiser, whatever year that is. I
can't do the math. 66 55 years later, so
it's fairly recent.
>> Yeah. Yeah. 2010, 2015, something like
that.
>> Right. And he's he says he's got um what
does he have a 16,000
piece swipe file o over time he's been
collecting swipes from direct mail and
email and whatever and he says I've
assembled every every ad that gene
mentions in breakthrough advertising I
have the ad like the space ad from like
girdles in you know in 19 in in 1950s
magazines And because Gene was making a
point in all of those ads and you know
he mentions the ads in breakthrough
advertising usually uses a headline or
something. He went out and got every
single ad.
So I said to him, "Man, what could we do
with this? This is awesome. It's like
the ultimate swipe file. It's the break
for advertising swipe file."
>> And then boot we had done a couple of
boot camps already and Chris and I Chris
actually was Chris's idea more than
mine. He said, "Let's put it all." I I I
said, "Let's let's use these swipes from
Louise in some kind of a book or a
special report or something." And then I
And then we said, "Why not take the
worksheets from the boot camp, put them
in a book, then put all the ads as part
two of the book, and it became
Breakthrough Advertising Mastery, and
>> it becomes a companion volume. Um, we
sell it for $75, I think 59 digitally.
Um, we don't sell Break for Advertising
digitally, but we sell Break for
Advertising Mastery. And
>> which which is pretty dense.
>> It is 500 pages. God damn it.
>> This thing This thing is thick and
>> Oh, we ship it to Australia. People are
freaked out how much the postage is.
>> Yeah. Well, cuz it's three pounds or
four pounds or whatever. And all the ads
are in the back.
>> All the ads.
which is incredible.
>> Incredible.
>> That was like, you know, just one thing
feeding on another. Um, and it's
interesting, you know, Jean Barb Jean's
wife, Barbara, when I send her a royalty
check every six months. She says, "I'm
not getting it. Why is Jean so much more
popular now than when he was alive?" But
we did a good job, you know, getting his
name out. He was legendary in in out in
the ether. Basically, the book was
basically mostly out of print for a long
time and you know um you know bringing
it back being a shepherd for Jean
Schwarz's work is one of the you know
definitely one of the highlights of my
career.
I love that. I love it. I think it's
important and honestly to Barbara's
point like why is Jean Schwarz more
important or not more important more
popular now than he was then? I love
that he's actually grown in popularity
be because candidly it's one of the
reasons I wanted to have this
conversation. I think we need it now
more more than ever. I think
>> you need to get some foundational stuff.
You can use AI all you want. It's great.
I love AI. I love I love chat GPT. I
love I love Claude. I love all of it.
>> But on on a on on a bed of sand, it's
not so good. on a bed of fundamental
eternal truths.
>> It's going to be better. Everything's
better on a bed. Everything's better
served on a bed of a bedrock
fundamentals. Everything is better
served on eternal with a with a with a
with a
with with a a base. You know how you get
you get in in the health food places,
you get a base and then you get the
protein and with a base of eternal
truth.
>> Yeah. No, absolutely. And and candidly
fundamentals
almost almost to me like when I think of
breakthrough advertising, I think of
like fundamentals on steroids. Like it
is the most advanced way of looking at
fundamentals. You mentioned it being
dense. It is dense. I barely got through
the first three chapters the first time
I bought.
>> That's why Paris Andropolis who talks
about he uses it with his copy cubs that
he coaches. He says, you know, you and
this is you could use you can I think
we've used this in some of the copy for
the boot camp, too. Basically, it's um
he said, and I do this when you buy the
book from me. There's a letter on on
attached to the book that says, "Read
the first three chapters three times
before going on to the rest of the
book." So, you can absorb that. You'll
get much more out of the rest of the
book. That's how Paris teaches it to his
copy cubs. He also says, you know, when
when I say to Paris, you know, isn't
breakthrough advertising the most
important book on copywriting and
marketing, he says it may be the most
important, but it ain't the first one
you should read.
>> You know, Paris Paris is not he he's the
he's the first one that really talked
about it as an advanced text in
marketing and copywriting. And so
doesn't mean you shouldn't be in your
library. It should it should be in every
copywriter and marketer's library. But
don't read it before you read scientific
advertising. Don't read it before you
read, you know, Olgvian advertising.
Don't read it even before you read the
call your sales letter book. Although
that's pretty pretty dry and dense, too.
Um
>> Yeah. Yeah. That's 1910, 1920 on that
one.
>> Yeah. I mean, I I um I don't know if it
is that old. Maybe 1940, but it's old.
It's old. Um, yeah, that's why my first
book with Craig Simpson, The Advertising
Solution, that was why I was I was
attracted to that book. Chris, uh, Craig
had done a lot of the leg work on that
book, the heavy lifting early on. And he
came to me, you want to co-author this
with me? And I I didn't know if I wanted
to or not. And I did. Once I saw what
the book was, it basically took the six
legends of advertising who were
basically um they were madmen. You know
the show Madmen?
>> Oh, of course. Yeah. You even talk about
madmen style uh marketing in overd
deliver where you're like that's just a
different concept to direct response.
Totally opposite. Right.
>> Exactly. Um, but basically these were
all the madmen and but they were they
were trapped because they were actually
direct response marketers but they were
trapped in a general advertising body
because direct marketing wasn't a thing.
But man, what was scientific about
advertising in 1923? Well, Claude
Hopkins knew.
>> Yeah.
>> David Oglevie knew in the 60s.
>> Schwarz knew in the 60s. Um, you know,
it it basically gave rise to all the
direct response divisions of Olgo and
Mather Direct and all the BBDO, all the
big ad agencies on Madison Avenue, all
the madmen ad agencies
developed a direct division,
>> Mather Direct, BBDO Direct, Wonderman
Direct. They were all that was that all
took place in my early days in marketing
in the 80s. Those were the hot agencies.
They were doing direct response in a
general advertising agency. So, it
wasn't general advertising anymore. It
was direct response. And the these six
legends that Craig wrote about and one
of them was Jean. So, it was like a
no-brainer for me to be part of that
book. But it was Gene Schwarz and Gary
Halbert were two of them. And then the
other four were like people you haven't
heard of even like even copyriters today
would hear of Gary Halbert and Jean
Schwarz if they're if they're anyone
who's going to go anywhere but they
might not they should have heard of
David Olglevy they might not have heard
of John Cables
who you know was basically the guy the
test the testing guy um Collier
salesletter book
>> um
>> um Claude Hopkins scientific advertising
so those six legends
were and so we basically were able to
digest the greatest hits from those six
legends. Couldn't do it for Gan because
you know breakthrough advertising was
too dense. You could put this in in I I
I never used this copy in the boot camp
but you could do something with it.
Maybe say that you know Brian wrote the
advertising solution covering the six
legends of advertising. You can list
them. Um and then say Jean was one of
them. And Brian always thought that he
could he couldn't do justice to Jean's
work cuz breakthrough advertising was so
dense and so so um um transformational.
>> Yeah.
>> That it needed something more. And so
when he republished Breakthrough
Advertising it needed something more.
And that became the boot camp. That
became Breakthrough Advertising Mastery.
Um so even and you can that that gives a
kind of you're you're basically um
anchoring to David Oglevie, Claude
Hopkins, Robert Collier, even Gary
Halbert. Gary Halbert never wrote a real
book. He had the Gary Halbert letter
which alleg Gary Halbert letter which is
legendary.
>> The Boron letters.
>> Oh, the Boron letters. Yeah, that's
Yeah, those were letters. But yeah, that
that that's an important book, right?
>> Oh. Oh, you just mean his newsletter
like his his actual like letter.
>> It it basically if you took his
newsletters and just assembled them,
it's one of the best books on
copywriting ever written.
>> Actually, funny story about that. I paid
a guy $200 on Upwork to chronologically
assemble them in a word document for me.
>> I think that Yeah. I mean, I don't I
don't know why uh Kevin and Bond never
did that.
>> Well, somebody did it. It was online for
a while cuz I asked I like I think I
tweeted it or something. It's not in
public domain. They Kevin and Kevin and
Bond are very productive.
>> Oh, whoops. I might have
>> noticed. Sorry, guys. Well, they're free
on the internet, so I was like, "Hey,
could somebody
>> Yeah, but they could have done more with
that." I mean, you know, I I I um
>> Yeah,
>> that that's that's hilarious. But those
are legends. Those are legends that
obvious So, I know a lot of people know
Halper. You're right. Capable is
probably under the radar a little bit.
Um there's
>> Collier's definitely under the radar.
Hopkins isn't under the radar in in
traditional copywriting circles like if
you're an AWAI copywriter cuz Clayton
Makepiece did a did everybody a big a
big a what a a big solid by
emphasizing
these guys. uh did so every time he had
a chance and he was a major speaker at
AWI for many years and there's a lot of
AWI graduates. Some of them are not good
copywriters, but they're at least they
graduated AWAI. But, you know, they
were, you know, Clayton gets a lot of
credit for that. Clayton
>> Yeah.
>> Uh, even more than more than Deutsch,
more than Paris, more than a lot of the
other guys in that generation, my
generation basically. Um,
um, I always give Clayton the most
credit because he just wanted to teach.
He wanted to be he was a professor of
copywriting.
But
>> I I candidly think Clayton Makepiece is
one of the most underrated I think he's
underrated in the circles that I'm in
today because most people don't know
about quick start.
>> No. No. And he he you know he only died
in 2020, you know. Um but I I'm going to
I'm going to It's funny when I reap but
I tell you this is good this is the good
news about him not being known or known.
one of my blog I write a blog when when
he died I did a I did a tribute podcast
um blog to him I repeated it
a couple of times since 2020 hadn't
repeated it in a while and Chris handle
Chris has I we have two Filipino um VAS
who takes uh uh pieces of my blog posts
and they post them on LinkedIn X uh
Facebook and the one That was
the the one that got the most response,
the most engagement of any we put up.
Not to say that my they get so many, but
it got a lot for for LinkedIn anyway.
Um, was my Clayton Makepiece piece.
>> Really?
>> Yeah. People who know who he is have the
same reaction you do.
How can this guy not be like talked
about with in the same breath almost?
Not quite, but as Halbert and Schwarz
and Ben Svena and Rutz, he's he's like
he's like almost right there.
>> Well, as far as like copyrightiting
education goes.
>> Yes, absolutely.
>> In that sense, Quick start when somebody
asks me because I have a lot of people
who are like, "Okay, what's the first
thing blah blah blah?" And outside of
like Joe Sugarman's AdWeek, copywriting
handbook, right? Claude Hopkins uh
scientific advertising. Outside of
those,
>> in your in one of your YouTube videos,
you had two other books besides
Sugarman, which I'm not as familiar
with, but if they're
>> I had the Bob Bllye one, which I think
is helpful if you
>> Which one? Copywriter's handbook.
>> Copywriter's handbook. I have that as
more like a pull it off if you need to
pull something off your shelf because
he's so diver it's such a diverse book
where he's like it talks about meta ads
and landing pages.
>> No, and Bob Bllye is one of the great
teachers as well. He actually, you know,
he's he he proves the point that you
don't have to do it to teach it. He's a
good copywriter. He was never like a
major A-lister
>> in the in the era of Bill Jamie and and
Jim Rutz and and Ben Sena.
Bill Bob Lie was a big step. I I I
tested him a few times at boardroom. He
just didn't have that that extra oomph,
but an amazing amazing teacher of the
craft.
>> Oh yes. Yes.
>> Tommy Lord, I don't know baseball Tommy
Lord was one of the worst baseball
players of all time and he's a Hall of
Fame manager. So you can do it. You can
do it.
>> Yeah. I mean again kudos to these guys
even even so like again the Clayton
makepiece to me is uh one of the best
teachers because when I read quick start
copywriting I was like where has this
been this is this is a toz everything I
was looking for.
>> Yeah like yeah he's yeah he was special.
>> Yeah it was it was absolutely
incredible. But again back to Jean like
I'm one I read one page into
breakthrough advertising. He writes this
line that's like you cannot create
desire. You have to channel mass desire.
Right. Right.
>> And then I I close not create desire.
>> Yes. I close the book and I'm like how
do I do that?
>> Yeah.
>> It's just like
>> the desire is already in the
marketplace. It's the copywriters
copyrer's job to
>> you know get find it get it together.
It's not you don't have to invent it.
>> No. No. And then he goes further and he
and he talks about like copy is
assembled and it goes back to, you know,
like what's not in the book and all this
stuff.
>> That's exactly right. That's what that's
what he meant by copy is assembled,
right?
>> Yeah. And I was like, dang it. Here I am
trying to sit here and come up with
these best headlines or whatever and
these guys are like, no, dude. Like look
around for a minute. Rouse around, dive
into it. Which is why the boot camp is
so applicable because you'll get a line
like that. And for me, I sat on it with
my I was like, I don't know what to do
with that. I don't even know what to do
with that. I don't even understand how
to figure that out.
>> Yeah. But also, that's what the So, the
boot camp, taking it right to the boot
camp, you've the reason why it's so
powerful is the worksheets that we put
together. The exercises that we do are
applicable to all businesses, all all
categories.
And so, that's the extra oomph that you
need. So you read something in
breakthrough advertising. How do I apply
that to my business? And so I know
you're going to write good copy for your
boot camp. You borrow whatever you want
from what we have. We have a lot. Hope
Chris sent you all the all the
>> He did. He sent me lots of stuff.
>> Okay. So but you can adapt, use, not
use, but I would definitely encourage
you to make it make the link between,
you know, obviously theory and practice.
And the practice is, you know, there's
homework inside the boot camp. If you
don't want to, you have to do it.
>> We're not going to take attendance. But,
you know, if you don't do it, you're not
going to get as much out of the boot
camp because and with the hot seat
availability inside the boot camp, you
actually can we can hot seat you on your
specific business how to use the the
concepts from breakthrough advertising.
How good is that?
>> Yeah, that's absolutely that's
absolutely incredible. Two weeks, six
calls, you know.
>> Yeah, that's Do do we have a date for
the boot camp? I know Chris was
>> We have the two weeks. We have the two
weeks. It's going to be
>> When is the two weeks?
>> Yeah, we we we'll get a schedule soon.
It's going to be the weeks of
October 20th and 27th.
Um, usually the first week it's Tuesday,
Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday or Tuesday,
Thursday, Friday, and then the second
week is usually maybe Monday,
Wednesday, Thursday, something like
that.
>> Yeah. What I what I think is insane,
again, the price six calls, we're
talking through the most legendary book
as far as like staple in fundamentals,
advanced fundamentals. You're going to
be on the call. Are you on these calls,
Brian?
>> Yes.
>> You're on these calls. This is And it's
297.
This is going to be easy to write.
>> Yeah.
>> But what I I I need I'm going to need to
go in a few minutes. So, tell me what um
what didn't we talk about that you
really wanted for your for your copy
based on the questions you sent?
>> Uh honestly, I think we hit practically
every everything. I wanted to make sure
we got I wanted
>> I mean number seven, you know, why
should copyrighters join us for a
breakthrough boot camp? And it's not
just copywriters,
>> you know, it's
>> it's it's it's marketers. It's it's
anybody in business um who wants to sell
more, market more. Um
>> you know, you got to be you got to be at
least you don't have to do the writing
yourself either. There'll be people on
the call that you might be able to hire
to do the writing for you, but that's
not the toughest thing. The toughest
thing is you as the entrepreneur, you as
the business owner getting getting your
arms around your market, how to approach
your market, how to, you know, how to
how to how to not create desire, how to
how to how to bring the desire together.
Um, and you know, um, assemble your
copy. And you don't have to assemble it
yourself by by using the worksheets
inside the boot camp. It's going to get
assembled for you. You might have like
if you don't want to write it, you can
actually use chat GPT to give you your
first draft off the worksheets that you
assemble from the boot camp.
>> That would be a first step in writing
your first promotion letter.
>> Yeah, huge, huge first step. Especially
because a lot of the worksheets uh in
the boot camp, I know Chris has them in
like Google Sheets and Excel formats
that you could just download, upload.
>> They're all downloadable. They're all
Yeah, they're all Yeah, it's it's a it's
a it's a good I mean, we've done eight
of them. This is going to be our ninth.
So, um
>> and each one is better than the next be.
That's another factor. Each one is the
the the best one is the one coming up
because and the one you'll experience
because it's a cumulative
effect of what worked in each one and
adding on and adding on and adding on.
So, and that's true. I mean, Chris uses
different ads in each boot camp. He he's
changed around some of the worksheets
based on and he's gotten them into I AI
a bit. Um, you know, it's it's not just
and that's another thing. It's like
don't think just because the book was
written in 1966
that you know obviously everything is
100% relevant today and we'll show you
by adapting AI to breakthrough
advertising.
>> Yeah.
>> Not to copy [__]
>> you know. It's not to copy [__] It's to
adapt and get your thinking and move
move the ball down the field, but you're
still going to have to do the work.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's the It's the strategy,
the approach, the thinking
>> right
>> behind it, right? The the leg work, the
finger work that changes over time, but
what he set in stone for how you
approached it
>> is completely timeless,
>> right? And and we made it practical,
too. So, it's timeless and practical.
>> I love it. I love it. Brian,
>> anything else that you
>> No, we talked about we talked about
everything. I mean, we bounced around on
some of the questions. I love it.
>> I'm a tangent waiting to happen, so I
went off of some tangents. I apologize.
>> No, I took it honestly that I was hoping
for it. Uh, obviously not my first time
listening uh to you. I've gotten to
listen to you from afar on Titans and
you've done interviews with Ben and all
this stuff. So, I was like, "Oh, this
will be fun. I don't even think we'll
make it through the questions." Which is
totally fine. We'll have a great time
with it. Um, but honestly, last plug,
obviously, this is going to is on my you
guys are watching this on my YouTube,
uh, which is going to go up. My email
list is going to hear about it. So, you
guys will get a ton of emails from me,
uh, about this. I'm going to be a part
of it. I'm going to be hanging out
there. Uh, Brian's going to be there.
Chris Mason's going to be there. This is
incredibly important. I think this is
one of the most prolific, uh, times that
we can actually do this. One of the most
prolific offers, at least of 2025. I'm
grateful that you're still doing it. Um,
so I I want to take advantage and I'm
going to make sure to write a ton of
copy. Anything you want to say uh to our
guys before one I'll say is this. We
don't we don't go out and find people to
promote the boot camp.
>> Um, you came to us.
>> I did.
>> So basically
um it's like you you don't you don't
choose your mentors. Your mentors choose
you. You don't choose who sells for you.
Your sellers choose you. So, you chose
us, which made it more than more than
obvious that we want you to do this for
us. We're not we're not looking for tons
of affiliates. We're not we're not in
the affiliate game. I you know, people
say I leave money on the table all the
time. I'm fine with that. I'm not I'm
not I'm not I'm not living for money.
I'm living for impact and and teaching
and all that. But you know, a young
copywriter knocks on our door,
we have to make sure he's legit. You
seem legit. Um, so uh um you know, and
you know, you're obviously earnest.
You're obviously on the on the way up,
uh big time. Um and so no downside for
us. All upside. All upside for you
because there won't be many people. Um,
I think Bob Lie happens to be promoting
this one actually. But that's it.
>> I'm gonna try and beat Bob.
>> Yeah, that that's it. Um, the other
thing I would say, you know, I was just
thinking all my tangents and stuff. One
of the things that you might be able to
work in without making it a negative is,
you know, it's hard to do this, but you
could say, you know, I I I had a call
with Brian, you know, just to talk about
the boot camp, get his input on it, so
I'd really understand it before I
experience it myself, which you're going
to experience it yourself.
>> Yeah. you'll be you're you know you got
comped for the whole boot camp obviously
but but then um basically you say
something like you know Brian said
always says he's a tangent waiting to
happen man did I experience that and and
you know what getting him back on track
to just talk about Gene and breakthrough
advertising was tough at times however
the education he gave me and how he he
brought it back to breakthrough
advertising he wasn't He wasn't on a
tangent off to the moon in a rabbit
hole. He went if there's a rabbit hole
on the moon, but he went off on a
tangent, brought it back because
everything revolves around, you know, um
original source around fundamentals
around eternal truths. So we talked
about Clayton Makepiece. We talked about
Paris Lampropolis. We talked about, you
know, um, bullet bullets and
fascinations and, you know, things that
Gan experienced that Paris does now. Or
you could you could work all of that in
and say, I guess Brian will be like that
on the calls. So, I hope you're ready
for some tangents that are tangents
without warning
that could yield incredible
epiphies or you may just get crazy with
this tangents. But either way, you know,
you can make it a little a little, you
know, somewhat deprecating to me if you
want to. I have no problem with that.
but turn into a positive that they're
getting 44 years of my experience of
whatever I can share as it relates to
gene and breakthrough advertising and
all tangents in in six calls.
>> Yeah, I'll definitely
>> there might be something there for you.
I don't know. There might be something
there for you.
>> It's uh it's the Ben settleism of making
the skeleton dance with your bullets. He
always says don't hide the skeleton in
the closet. Wave it out in front of them
and use it to sell. I'll I'll figure out
a way to shake that one out and uh and
it'll be fun. But I'm genuinely I'm
excited. Again, I think it's incredibly
important to get in front of people
today. So, I am excited to be on the
calls, to hang out, to share this uh
with the people, and to get to spend
more time listening to the tangents
because we did weave back. No problem.
>> Oh, that that that goes without saying
when you're on a call with me. So,
>> well, perfect. Well, I do want to honor
your time. I know you have to go. Um, I
appreciate even just giving me the time.
It It truly means a lot uh to me. It
really does. So, thank you, Brian. I'm
I'll email you and and work out like a
hey, when this can go live, when I'll
send the emails type thing just to just
so we're aligned on that because I want
>> Yeah, make sure I mean Chris is going to
handle that piece mostly, but I can be
on the emails, but yeah, I
>> I'll send it to Chris. Yeah, I I I'm
don't know what your what your Colby is,
but mine is 5393 and the three is follow
through.
>> Yeah,
>> my nine is quick start. So, yeah. Um I I
I you don't want to rely on me for the
nitty-gritty details. I mean, I know the
details and I can get them to you, but
rely on Chris for that. Not but keep me
in the loop. You can CC me on anything.
>> Uh and I I'll chime in if I think I got
something additional. Perfect. Yeah,
I'll I'll uh I'll align with Chris. I
just want to make sure on promotion
timelines and things like that.
>> That'll be all Chris. Well, he and I
gonna discuss it and then it's all him.
Carla needs to be in the loop a little
bit cuz she's also handles my schedule.
So, um but that's more Chris and Carla.
So, that's not you. That's okay.
>> No worries. I'll I'll take care of it.
We'll get this done and then I'll I'll
send over all the collateraliz.
>> You get us a lot of uh a lot of um a lot
of attendees. How big is your list?
>> Uh it's it's almost 4,000 now. Almost
4,000.
>> Nice.
>> Um which again it is. I've definitely
followed the more Ben Settle small and
mighty list.
>> Yeah, that's what mine is too. Mine
don't buy though,
>> generally.
>> Oh, really? I mean, they'll buy the boot
camp and stuff, but I I've trained them
to almost not buy because my my blog,
it's all PS's in my blog. I'm not I'm
not I'm not comfortable with, you know,
and I do I do what I want to do, you
know, it's my blog. I can do what I want
with it. But, I mean, we've sold we've
we've done a little bit. We once did a
launch for Titans Accelerator, you know,
a series of emails. I I rarely do that.
I'll do it once in a while, but I' it's
sort of like Joe Polish says, I'm the
director of sales prevention and you
know, uh, sometimes,
but I I'm I'm good with that. I wear it
like a badge of honor because I'm I'm
I'm I'm value and content first. And I
don't recommend that to everybody. I
mean, you know, Ben's style is so
effective and so powerful. Your style is
your style. It's it's obviously
effective. Um, you know, you got to you
got to be your own person. But so my my
list is, you know,
they don't they're not they're just
don't I trying to You think I be I
should be able to sell Titans
Accelerator
membership straight up on my email list
and I I don't.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. That's okay. I mean,
again, everybody, it took me a while to
figure out how to like, okay, am I doing
this right? Am I doing this wrong?
There's no right or wrong.
>> Yeah. I mean, metric metric-wise, I'm
always like, can I do big launch?
>> That's true. That's true.
>> Um, but in that launches typically, we
have a lot of fun with launches because
Right. I mean, you you learn along the
way, you know, add some bonus.
>> Yeah, I learned a lot for launches. I
did. Absolutely.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Well, yeah. I
mean, you have significantly more
knowledge in it than I do. That's for
sure. knowledge, not that not a ton of
of of firsthand experience, but I mean
I've done multiple launches, but you
know, everything I did in my career was
a launch of sorts. You know, it's like,
>> you know, doing doing a million piece
direct mail uh campaign, it's a launch.
>> See, you're way overqualified for the
Jeff Walker mastermind. I don't
>> I could I can make a case whether the
case would be agreed to. I don't know.
>> I'll take it. I'm going to have a ton of
fun with this one. All right, good
promote it.
>> Awesome. Awesome. Brian, if there's
anything I could do for you, just reach
out.
>> All right, great. Allan,
>> thanks, Brian. I appreciate it. See you
>> later. Bye.